Can I share one more testimony? You guys
don't mind? I was crying yesterday. If
you guys would you let me share this
testimony. A voice from my past
and I'm thinking about I'm going to cry.
Can I share one story? A young man
reached out to me that man I went to his
page and I started tearing up.
I can't share his Facebook page. I'm
going to read what he sent me on
Facebook. Remember I told you before I
went into full-time ministry, before I
went to full-time ministry, I used to
work as a security guard in five South
Wabash
jewelers row jewelers row 21 floors of
jewelry in downtown Chicago.
At that time, I was a diehard Christian
Zionist because I didn't know any
better.
God used me to show love to all the
people. Many of them were Jews. Some
were Orthodox Jews. To my shock, a young
man who was probably in his teenage
years found me on this page. I'm going
think about I'm going to cry.
Look what he sent me.
I reached out to him and I talked to him
on the phone and
said, "I'm going to start crying."
That's what he sent me. I try to be as
honest as I can with my story. Look what
he sent me.
Here's my witness that I have not lied
to you. I've tried to be honest with
you. I was a security. He sent this to
me. What's up, my friend? Is it possible
you're the security guard at the Mer
building in Chicago?
You took me to see the movie Spawn when
I was a kid. Beautiful Orthodox Jewish
boy.
I came across your page in some video
where you talked about Jesus.
He found me. Look what he says. I go,
"That was me."
Look what he says.
Watch it. Look what he says here.
He goes, "Holy moly, Miller's the best
from the West." You remember? He
remember when I would sing songs about
his dad and his uncles on his mother's
side. He remembered me. Can you believe
it? And I talked to him.
He's a grown man.
All his siblings are now married and
they have children. Now, let me tell you
something why this hit me and reminded
me of something. Okay? I want to tell
you something about me. This is not
dogmatic teaching.
I'm not a priest.
I'm not a prophet.
You just ignore my own feelings. I'm
just telling you me as a man.
I've met some of the most beautiful
people from different traditions. I met
some beautiful Orthodox Jews. I've met
some beautiful secular Jews
that tried to live moral lives and were
good people.
This family was one of them. He
remembered me because his father fell
into a coma while my dad was dying
and I saw him in the hospital. Sadly,
his father never recovered. Neither did
my father. So you know what he told me?
He told me man that his father came to
him in dreams appeared to him in dreams
after he died because his father died
relatively young. A good man he's a
spartic Jew. A good man. And I go thank
you for sharing that with me because I
told him I go you know I'm a Christian.
I believe in Jesus but I also believe
this is me. Please don't condemn me man.
I'm not telling you this is what the
church teaches. I'm telling you me as a
human who has issues. I also believe
right.
I also believe
that God meets people where they're on
and God sees their heart sincerely and
if they don't know the gospel, they
don't know who Jesus is but have sought
to live moral lives to their conviction,
they will be saved because of the grace
of Jesus Christ. Let me repeat. No one
is saved without Jesus. Please don't
misquote me. Don't take me out of
context. Man, dude, I'm puffed up today.
Damn.
Don't take me out of context.
Don't misquote me. Nobody is saved
without Jesus.
The question is, can Jesus in his
infinite love and mercy save people who
to no fault of their own have not heard
the true gospel known the true Jesus but
have only been exposed to a caricature.
Okay? Why? Because if you ask Orthodox
Jews, they identify Jesus with Gentiles
coming with a cross and a sword. That's
just their picture. I'm not saying it's
true. slaughtering the Jews who would
not believe in Jesus. And many of them
are even shocked to find out Jesus is
Jewish.
You with me there? All right. They have
not heard what the gospel is. They have
not read the New Testament to see that
the authors of the New Testament, the
exception of one are Jews. They have not
understood that Jesus is God who became
a descendant of David.
of the tribe of Judah and they have not
understood that Christians celebrate the
greatest creature
is a woman who is Jewish. They don't
know this
because they don't know my conviction
and this is me. I'm just giving you my
own testimony. I cannot accept but God
forgive me that there are people who
don't know who the real Jesus is gospel
who are suffering
who are starving who are struggling
who are relatively good doing their best
to live upright moral lives who are not
terrorists who are not murderers who are
not rapists who are not molesters who
don't fornicate
I can't imagine that Jesus will damn
them to hell
I just don't see that in this is me.
This is me. I'm not saying this is the
church teaching. You go with what the
church says. This is me. When he told me
his father appeared,
that blessed my heart to know because he
was a good man. He was. His father was a
good man.
And you can tell he's a good man because
he raised up four good boys. They're
grown men with families. good people. He
was a good man. Now his father is saved,
perfected,
and he now knows who the real Jesus is.
No one is saved without Jesus. But if
you end up in heaven because Jesus had
mercy on you, pied you, and loves you,
and knew to no fault of your own, you
did not know who he really was. This my
conviction, man.
Right? This is my conviction. It's what
I see.
So, I won't be shocked. Many Christians
don't make it to heaven. I pray I'm not
one of those who don't make it. And I
won't be shocked if I see a multitude
of people, Indians,
Pakistanis,
Afghanis, Chinese, Japanese, ethnic Jews
who are all there in heaven. Even though
on earth they didn't know Jesus, they
didn't know the gospel. They were not
Christian. But that little light that
they received, they acted upon it. And
then Jesus saves them, perfects them,
and now they know who Jesus is. Not
going to be shocked.
That's my conviction. So guys, don't
condemn me. Go with what the church
says. I'm a human being
and I am weak and I am imperfect,
sinful. When I see children suffering,
older women suffering, children who are
dying of cancer and their parents are
devastated. I don't see a Jewish child,
an Indian child. I don't see a Japanese
child, a Russian child. I see children
whom Jesus loves, whom he is in love
with, whom he created. That's who I see.
And I cannot believe that the Lord's
heart doesn't break for them and he
brings them into his presence. I just I
don't see that.
This is just me. Condemn me to hell if
you want. Just just me. It's because the
more I get to know Jesus,
the more I see the heart of Jesus, the
more I see how infinitely beautiful and
loving compassion is and how he goes out
of his way
to save and goes out of his way not to
destroy.
That's just me.
That's what I think. I hope I'm not
wrong.
I hope I'm not wrong. I really do
because I can't imagine someone like
that in hell. I can't imagine that. I
can't.
Their father was a beautiful man.
Beautiful man.
I just cannot imagine someone like him
that wasn't saved. I can't imagine that.
In fact, if it was up to me, hell would
be purgatory. Everyone in hell goes
there and gets purged and comes out and
saved if it was up to me. But I'm not
God. I'm not perfect. My love is not
perfect. My justice is not perfect. I
don't know. I trust in him. That's it.
It's like Abraham said, "Far be it from
you to treat the righteous with the
wicked. Shall not the judge of all the
earth do what is right?" See, Abraham
knew his God. So anyway, that just when
he reached out to me, I've been going on
his Facebook page. I'm in awe. He's
grown
with children and his brothers are man.